Microsoft's Xbox one has only been out
for a couple of years but already people
are using it for amazing things it's not
just a console it's also a great
multimedia entertainment system and if
you've been thinking about picking up an
Xbox one but aren't quite sure I've got
four reasons why an Xbox one should be
your console for this holiday season
number for the new xbox one experience
Microsoft just brought a huge update to
the Xbox one that includes a new
community section and upgraded one guide
if you're interested in a one-stop shop
for your games TV and movies and more
it's a much faster experience that makes
getting your content easier which is
always a good thing and speaking of good
things the new xbox one experience also
brought one massive upgrade in
particular number three backwards
compatibility one of the coolest
announcements made at e3 this year was
the fact that you can pop in your old
360 games and they will download and
play on your xbox one it's not every
single game but as a press time there
are over a hundred of them including
classics like burnout paradise and that
list is only going to grow over time as
publishers are able to give the go-ahead
for their games here's the hoping red
dead redemption gets the nod soon come
on rockstar we know you can do it number
two customizable controller inputs
tagging along with the xbox elite
controller which honestly is so amazing
is an app for the Xbox one that allows
you to remap controller commands it's a
really nice gesture that lets users
customize their experience and Microsoft
added this functionality to every
official controller now look for it
built into the new update in the
settings menu are the Xbox accessories
app if you already have that no longer
will you accidentally throw a sticky
grenade up and onto your helmet and halo
5 when you meant to reload because
you're used to the way a different game
doesn't you're in control and I'll never
do that again and the number one reason
why the Xbox one is the console for you
is the great games that you can only
find on xbox the Xbox has some real
powerhouse franchise exclusives that
will make the decision to get down with
Microsoft a good one you got halo 5 you
got all future gears of war games all
the forces state of decay the upcoming
scalebound and crackdown and at least
until the end of 2016 right
is of the tomb raider oh so good picking
up an Xbox one is a solid choice this
holiday season and beyond Microsoft is
under a lot of pressure to make sure
that the xbox one experience is the best
it can possibly be for all kinds of
gamers and with access to your 360
library customizable inputs and a whole
bunch of exclusive amazing franchises on
the Xbox it's going to be a really
exciting year for Microsoft